I have a teenage daughter,
and I feel like the younger generations
really just have life figured out.
Anytime she does something,
she makes me laugh.
She will talk about herself as if she'll.
She'll kind of start saying what the crowd would be saying
if she was on stage.
So, like,
she washes the dish and she's like,
she did that great.
She. She will speak about herself as if there was an audience there
and that's what they're saying.
And now I've kinda gotten in the habit of that.
So anything I do,
I then say kind of like,
she looks amazing today.
Like, that's what,
you know, the people would be saying if they saw me.
And it has been quite a mind fuck and really just makes me laugh.
Like, I constantly have people, like,
cheering me on and saying,
dope shit, but it's me.
But your brain is tricky that way,
so you should try that.
Just, you know,
cheer yourself on all day long.
She did that. She looks amazing.
She killed it.
Her hair. Killing it.
Just speak about yourself amazingly and you'll start to fall for it.